california arizona colorado increasingly
intense wildfires have carved a path of
devastation through the american west
over the past few years and as the pace
of climate influence disasters pick up
insurance payouts and government aid
packages are getting bigger as well
that's creating windfalls for the
disaster restoration industry these
companies have responded by hiring
workers who can travel from one
catastrophe site to another
joining us now is saket sony he is
founder and director of resilience force
this is a nationwide initiative that
seeks to bolster america's resilience
workforce socket welcome to the show
give us the quick take on this group who
are they what's the profile of a typical
worker and what does the work they do
entail
well
for millions of people
who live
and try to survive during wildfires and
floods and hurricanes
as soon as the as soon as those
disasters are over they need to rebuild
um so you know hundreds of thousands if
not millions of homes
schools
hospitals all need to be rebuilt very
quickly
so that people can come home so the kids
can go back to school so that a whole
tax base can come back the people doing
that rebuilding are the resilience
workforce these are usually immigrant
workers
if they're us born they're often people
of color um either way
come from uh poverty and they go from
disaster to disaster as these disasters
have grown in frequency and
destructiveness the workforce have grown
and so these are the workers who arrive
uh into the suburbs of colorado in the
last few weeks or kentucky after fires
or
or tornadoes and are now
you know undertaking the long slog of
rebuilding those communities
how many workers are there um and and
how do they get from one site to the
next i mean how do they get their jobs
well there's tens of thousands um but
there are not nearly enough the scale of
these disasters
and the need for climate adaptation the
need to make our homes our schools our
hospitals
resilient to face the climate risk is so
great that we actually need hundreds of
thousands of workers who deploy much
like the national guard to places where
disasters hit and help repair and not
just help repair the way things were but
build back um buildings so that they are
stronger in the face of the next
hurricane or flood or fowl
or fire they get their jobs right now
outside of home depot or through temp
agencies um or on facebook marketplace
small subcontractors
look for these workers and bring them to
sites
part of what we need is a much more
professionalized much more formalized
workforce
so that
these can turn into good jobs that that
people can make
careers out of and support families in
and one of your concerns is the kinds of
abuses that they suffer on the job give
us a sense of what that entails because
you mentioned the national guard which
comes in and essentially
volunteers their labor and and does the
work on behalf of the government calling
them in but in the case of the migrant
workers that you're talking about they
are hired by subcontractors uh for the
big disaster restoration companies uh on
a daily basis or on a gig basis for a
specific project so there are a lot of
work abuses that take place right
that's right the national guard stays
for weeks and volunteer
the resilience workforce
undertakes work that lasts years
lake charles louisiana is still being
rebuilt from the hurricane that hit two
years ago there are still parts of
houston that are being rebuilt
since hurricane harvey hit
four or five years ago so this work
lasts a long time and along the way
these workers suffer untold abuse we've
had members
fall through roofs without harnesses
and
and end up with broken bones and and
broken bodies
untold number of workers
suffer wage theft year after year season
after season part of the reason
is because these subcontractors are so
unaccountable
you know there's so much money coming
from the federal government
and from large investors into
the resilience economy into the disaster
rebuilding industry but at the bottom
there are very few protections for these
workers so they suffer wage theft
often when they ask for bathroom breaks
or the right to
safety equipment
they're let go
if they protest those abuses
immigration is often called on them um
you know this is not a work environment
in which these workers are thriving even
though the work is as necessary and
essential as it is right and you filed
class actual lawsuits on behalf of these
workers and actually won them back pay
in the process but doing so really pits
the workers against the companies that
hire them or in this case the
subcontractors and it doesn't really get
to the heart of the problem which is
building accountability from uh into the
industry from the top all the way down
to the smallest subcontractor how do you
go about doing that
you're absolutely right and that's why
we're calling on the investors
of these companies the people who invest
in them and profit from
um the viability of these companies to
push these companies
to sign on to our standards
the
companies like servpro
who who have been repeat offenders
servpro is a company we literally get
litigated against numerous times because
of the abuses of its franchisees and its
subcontractors
rather than spending that time
uh
in court rather than eating up a judge's
time
um we'd much rather invite these
companies to embrace a set of standards
um and and um you know comply with those
standards so that homes cities
schools buildings can get rebuilt faster
and more reliably after disasters as
you're talking about this i'm thinking
about how much more complicated the
resilience workers work is during covid
and especially something like omicron
when the virus is so contagious uh
they're all essential workers they're
all front line workers so it's not as if
they can quarantine uh for ten days and
and the work can wait um what kind of
existing laws are there to protect these
workers even though many of them are
undocumented they're migrant workers and
um they're not neces the subcontractors
they work for aren't necessarily
held to the same standards as as larger
companies
the laws are very weak and
you know what laws exist aren't worth
the paper they exist on because there is
very little enforcement i remember in um
the incredibly severe hurricane season
we had last year i was with workers in
louisiana
working at the bottom end of
big contracts repairing hundreds and
hundreds of
homes roofs entire school districts and
these workers were telling us that when
they contracted covid and told their
supervisors they needed day off or they
would infect their colleagues their
co-workers um
the
the subcontractors wouldn't allow it you
know the supervisors of these work sites
um we've found very frequently forced
people to work despite the fact that
they have coveted
very often refuse
requests for ppe
and safety equipment uh when workers are
symptomatic they're refused the
opportunity to get tested again and
again we've seen um
and this was in fact the subject of um
our litigation
against servpro where workers at the
bottom of that contracting chain found
themselves with kovid while building
michigan um
hospitals after uh two big dam breaks
last year um and you know they weren't
allowed to quarantine they weren't
allowed to
um to take time off from work and
eventually they were let go rather than
given the chance to heal and go back to
work and finish what they came for i see
well when we talk about solutions beyond
litigation which as you said takes up a
lot of time and doesn't necessarily
solve the problem you have launched a
pilot program in new orleans which of
course is home to far too many storms
and disaster what does that program do
and how can it be a blueprint for
something
that we can see in other cities
well in new orleans in partnership with
the city
and other stakeholders
and really because of the leadership of
the mayor we've partnered with the city
and
taken
low wage minimum wage service industry
workers who were laid off
because of covid people who lost their
jobs
in the
unemployment crisis that came after the
pandemic
and we retrained them and we turned them
into
resilience workers and we built a
resilience core
that faced into the covid disaster and
the climate disaster
we think that core should spread it
should spread to
places like california where the
wildfires require it
places like kentucky and colorado where
flooding tornadoes and um
uh
you know and and and other severe
weather events um
create a need for workers to meet
construction needs and human needs
and you know as the united states looks
at how to build a civilian conservation
corps the resilience corps in new
orleans is a great model you take people
who are out of work you retrain them you
turn them into people uh who will work
year round making buildings and
communities safe
before the next disaster and repair
buildings and communities
after disasters hit yeah you can solve
more than one problem at a time that way
socket really appreciate your taking the
time to explain everything you do socket
sony is founder and director of
resilience force